hello hello is this glowing I'm going to
clean lens real quick and ones here John
I thought people will be here
no one's here to celebrate you I thought
they'd be here so quick so quick hi bat
fans you out what a weird name that is
yeah what does that mean Green bulk
hello everyone
night vision walk night vision wolf
Trinity help do you listen to air and
air more that's quick thank you guys for
all the birthday mark I know the name
and I listen to some metal but I don't
know any of them on tomorrow's music's
but there's a guy who follows us on
instagram who loves them I just wanted
to hop in really quick and tell you guys
thank you so much for being here
honestly I'm pretty I love you too Rob
Slater one a - I'm just pretty I feel
like pretty good about my birthday this
year you know we had a really cool week
last week I got to get away this weekend
kind of a short film in the blazing a
hot desert and now back here and I just
wanted to say hi to you guys thank you
guys so much throwing a little shindig
on Saturday and then on yeah everyone's
invited and then tonight gonna see a few
friends gonna go to a bar
oh yeah yeah it's too [ __ ] up Oh Curt
Anderson I thought you don't want
shoutouts Anderson thank you buddy
mr. Enders hi John and I will buy me a
drink today thank you guys thank you so
much so look right away I'm gonna reveal
to you guys what dopes truck number
three is okay if in case you guys know
what dope trope is dope trope is
something I've come up with they're
basically the tropes in movies and shows
that I either noticed am stick up or I'm
okay with but here's one that and or
there's ones that I just don't hear too
many people point out so dope truck
number three for today would have to be
when foreign carrot
is taken hostage and then close to the
finale of the movie they actually speak
English as an how their character goes
you speak English
you've been able to speak English this
whole time yeah that's the one
that's dope trope number three for you
guys one day I'll make a little
compilation of you know all these dope
tropes and hopefully people give a [ __ ]
about them so you know we'll see anyway
guys amantha as much as I appreciate all
the happy birthday things John won't you
point out a question about live stream
let's do an open Q&A right now oh this
is open Q&A will be fun hey Michael
Michael Burnett thank you brother really
appreciate that go check now Omni media
as soon as you can especially because
he's using this money for his regal
stubbs
pass to come here but any questions any
quite a feat joke of all time oh I told
this joke on set I told this joke on set
when I was away and it did not go over
well actually people seemed a little
upset at me for making this joke and I
was like whoa I don't know why to seem a
B you know a joke I'm gonna tell I know
exactly
John how did Captain Hook die oh I don't
know how he wiped his ass with the wrong
hand
all anyone did is look at me like like
it took serious offense Jeff told this
joke a billion times I don't care if you
think it's stupid disgusting he's not
not funny but I've never heard someone
go I've never seen some people look at
me like why would you I don't know I
don't know if it had to do the fact
there were a couple of gay guys there I
might be reading into this and I was
like is there something because of like
bad experiences that have happened
that's just where my mind went was when
now I've made the situation worse by
saying that right here this is fave oh
did you watch the new Dave Chappelle
special did you know yet but I've heard
a lot of talk of
including Jeremy Jones and Janine
Washington go check out their thoughts I
thought it was pretty funny I wasn't
like in stitches
I feel I had an intra I was on screen
junkies in the use today thank you guys
so much for every was saying happy
birthday I was on screen junkies news
today and on the way back I was talking
with Ed Grier about how satire is viewed
now and how people have to really clear
up that they're making jokes and which
is not real satire it's like when I
would go by Ryan Wright and do my fandom
entertainment description which is makes
vulgar sex jokes usually directed at his
female guests and now I have to if I
ever make a G joke I have to clarify him
okay here's the context of the joke
here's why I made the joke is what the
joke means yeah which makes all comedy
better honestly but I thought it was I
thought it was really funny I mean there
are some jokes in there Rose like whoa
can't believe he said that or can't
believe we did that but I think the day
it was just to me they're just jokes to
me they're they're just jokes
I don't like and he's the way he's set
especially with that clip that's been
going around that they used to promote
the special that Netflix put out it's
like they're just jokes like this whole
setup is how he feels like if whatever
he says you can get in trouble for a
year from now tomorrow 10 years from now
so he's just making like super edgy
jokes that's just kind of how I viewed
it you know yeah I mean I find it
interesting how crazy charged up comedy
gets now and I don't really know where
to fall on it cuz half of me yeah half
of my mind is just like this is some
dude up on a stage telling jokes it
doesn't really have back to me that much
beyond do I agree with the point of view
do I appreciate it or not I do think
it's interesting by the way that we yeah
are dealing with how to touch touchy
topics yes the public forum and I yeah I
don't know I don't think anybody should
cancel Dave Chapelle or anything it is
weird especially when people can just
grab something you said from any point
in time and oh yes to you now it's yes
hey Michael Roy Bal thank you so much I
will have an awesome birthday
well what I'm drinking tonight I don't
know yet couple of friends are going I'm
a vodka cranberry drinker glass round it
down like a dude in prison come on I'm a
tough son of a [ __ ]
oh yeah but I heard that the place are
going to its tequila Tuesday's Oh which
means I'm gonna get in a violent Rachel
fit and oh thank you so much
insanity that's what we're going with
yeah if you could choose one movie
series to be in what would it be star
wars Avengers Lord of the Rings etc okay
okay look there's two ways to take this
question do I want to live in this as if
it's the real world or which one what I
want to like acting or be involved and
own a gun like a some creative side from
a creative side I would probably say
Avengers because the MCU actually DC I
would say DC I'm pretty passionate about
like a bat per se if you watch the
screen don't you sneeze I gave some
ideas of how I'd imagine like a bat
verse to go and what I'd want to do with
that man so I'd actually say DC for that
purpose one I'd want to live in
none of those choices like those are all
like everything's on the line we're all
gonna die so people say Game of Thrones
like no you wouldn't you would not want
to live in that world trust me you
wouldn't living you would die awful it's
like people say the Batman world like no
if I was just some dude in Gotham I get
my ass kicked have you seen cop it's
sheriff I would never want to be John
what world would you want to live in
what Laurel would I wanna live in I
would want to live in like the world of
Willy Wonka and the Chocolate Factory
that's a good choice Yeah right
it's just heightened did not yeah would
make the right choices that's a good
choice yeah because you could just enjoy
yourself and have fun
Yeah right you have to worry about
[ __ ] dying unless you're an [ __ ]
because that's how they die in there
I've demonetized this video long ago hey
whoa Aaron masters thank you so much
buddy you're
Bom Matt beer haven't heard from you in
a long time thank you thank you very
much
al-fayed Henry John look or what I'll
fee it means all right let's mat right
here what am I gonna see you again
you're supposed to come back to
California and also in the meantime
shoot me another question John all right
here's another question guys keep those
questions coming you're the ones who
fuel this live stream and seriously I'm
happy to be here right now because you
guys have made this a killer a year for
us it's been a really really successful
year hey what's my boobs dead what's
your favorite remake or reboot if it
favorite remake or reboot yeah you know
I'm gonna steal yours I really like the
maniac remake in terms of a remake I'd
also say Ocean's eleven because let's
face it that one's more that seems to
have redefined what the Ocean's eleven
franchises and Plus are here I it's I
think I saw Ocean's eleven when I was a
kid the like the Frank Sinatra one and I
remember being just bored but I really
like the Oracle anyone thank God my
girlfriend Olivia's not here to hear me
say that she would get mad at me
Brandon Tex thank you so much buddy if
you could have one theme song for oh it
really quick did you find his name no no
exist it's a hard name to find if you
could have one theme song for every time
you enter the room filled with large
people what would it be
mine would be all-star or Dark Knight
music oh my god
I would probably want Aerosmith's walk
this way okay I just feel like I could
just go it in slow motion anywhere with
that theme song or I would choose
goodbye my lover just cuz it would not
really fit most situations and it was
just really sad and make me laugh yeah
the song music yeah that's what I want
who is this man and then everyone will
have a flashback and remember all the
times I touched their lives without them
knowing
it'll be your theme song John just the
song music okay that's gene Jeter warmer
top rewards here patrons or go check out
the gene Jeter YouTube channel he made a
try not to laugh of the real rejects you
go check it out or Dirty Harry by
Gorillaz do you really want me to sing
happy birthday to your genes question is
can John sing happy birthday to Greg get
ready for it guys we got a selfie stick
do it John you know he jokes around but
he's got a good voice in there too as
well in case you guys haven't noticed I
stretched them pipes very nice job thank
you so much wait guys I gotta show you
my sister got me this Central Perk shirt
I know John got me this Britney Spears
Funko pop in case you guys don't know I
know I am a very big Britney Spears bad
I am I've had serious conversations as
of late about going to Vegas and
catching her live show guilty I know it
doesn't really make sense with the kind
of music I usually say I like which is
Eminem Red Hot Chili Peppers Franz
Ferdinand and Britney Spears it's very
true I really do I really do love
Britney Spears Eric the groundhog guy
thank you so much dude what series would
you like to start and during your
birthday happy birthday a birthday
whatever you want I'll take the birthday
cuz let's I don't I can't get drunk
tonight I can't because I got to come
back and shoot stuff for patreon YouTube
tomorrow so later tonight yeah yeah I
don't want you know I want to make sure
that I I'm not all [ __ ] hungover
oh I know it's not fun to react it yeah
yeah review don't like fake one any
awake or yeah so what series you like to
star in during your birthday yeah this
is like an updated version of the last
question I would like to play
Kuklinski the serial killer in mine
hunter season 3 that that is a great
game also someone asked about my hunter
season two three episodes away from
finishing it loving it so far loving it
so far I can't say where I'm at cause it
would spoil it but love it there's a
scene if you guys haven't seen mine
hunter season - aye-aye-aye show John
this scene just this one scene in season
2 where they interview a guy in a truck
and you don't see his face the whole
time he's in the backseat that is one of
the most brilliantly directed scenes
I've ever seen done you guys like that
if you guys have seen the show you'll
know what scene I'm talking about
[ __ ] amazing I haven't anyone else
talked about it but it like the next day
I'm like John I got to show you this
scene from my hunter yeah it was so good
so good and that beer will be back soon
okay thanks for the super chat man you
don't have to you know reply to me with
just a super thank you I really
appreciate it thank you so much thank
you so much I'm stapling you to thank
you dude that's really kind Oh somebody
says that New Mutants is still coming
out next spring it's not it's not it's
not coming out next spring if you could
watch oh wait we got
MC Polly I wrecked my dad's car today
without a permit that's bad news I've
wrecked a tire without a permit before
thanks for thanks really happened once
I feel like thank you thank you MC Pauly
I feel like you should put this money
toward the car but thank you I don what
are you cutting your hair
ah one of the questions whenever
whenever the mood strikes me and I find
a different haircut that I feel
compelled to get John and I have those
hairstyles where people will say when
are you gonna get a haircut and then the
other side is I really love your hair
and you get that compliment the other
half the times here like I don't know
people well to answer your question my
dude this is my last day of the my point
is my first day of the last of my 20s
put that together 29 years old yeah okay
here's a question from William Garcia if
you could watch any movie with any
celebrity what movie in Y and I'm gonna
add which celebrity which was the
question I'm sorry if you could watch
any movie with and
a celebrity which movie would you watch
and I'm gonna add which celebrity okay
look I'm gonna I'm gonna slightly flip
your question around but I've always
want to do this I've always wanted to
show Tom Cruise our opening Mission
Impossible sketch yeah for the Mission
Possible follow reaction if you guys
haven't seen it there's a playlist with
all the videos that I've sketches at the
beginning and the other one was a few
years ago I wrote a poem that ended up
turning into a rap song while I was
recording it for Ryan Gosling very
vulgar very heartfelt very heartfelt
though and I would always always wanted
to see if Ryan Gosling every combat
because that was a blast
today is my birthday yeah and Eric's
sauntered a slap John will he be able to
do it it's it's gotta be a $2.00 it's a
$2 slap oh no this is gonna start it
well if we make money though however we
just really just really enacted in slow
motion
we lost 15 viewers since doing that they
lost 15 viewers it's taken character for
you and everything by the way it's also
Keanu Reeves his birthday today
and Charlie Sheen yours last night
either way a honorees are now rather
than same time for both virgos and for
sure it's Charlie Sheen's birthday and
Saint Gregory the Great spur day was not
named after him isn't that ironic but
you were named many many years yes
Benson you're new you're awesome man
I love you Pokemon master Jon Oh your
attorney 26 on Saturday dude thank you
so much food you should have just kept
that super chat for yourself then but
now it's ours we will use it a great
party okay we got to go back to being
I'm joking I am joking I mean I'm not
joking about us you know keeping it but
I'm making a joke about Jack Dillon
grazers birthday apparently Jack Dillon
grazer from it and you know okay thanks
for Keanu Reeves birthdays the second
Charlie Sheen's is the third like you
mean like me no garages in here Roger
lost 15 pounds ladies if you live in New
Jersey
you're like a hot-looking Indian dude go
check him out as soon as you can give me
in question John
give us a question right there Kristen
so many of you thank you guys for all
the birthday wishes I feel the energy we
got people who want to suggest dope
Tropes
oh dude if you guys got dope trove celeb
it'll submit them below please favorite
character on friends who favorite
character I'm friends I've always been a
Chandler guy and I have feel like you
would I've always been a Chandler guy
[Music]
Chandler's always in my favorite when I
was really young and going like really
really really young um whenever that
episode came out where he saw the
Phoebe's dating a therapist and he
points out how he
blocks pain with humor I remember having
like a really young kid having a note of
I should do that and then I started a
very sarcastic sense of you yeah that
sounds like a great idea and a better
way to cope at this age who are we gonna
do any more cards probably we're just
regular corridor channels I mean we do
if we cover another youtubers video we
really do our best to try to you know
give our own input and really compliment
and highlight and also you know review
their video of an add-on to their video
as well and so you know we get a lot of
messages of youtubers to when we're at
to other videos are the same like thank
you so much for covering that in blah
blah blah which was always like we
screenshot those actually we really like
those but haven't heard anything from
Korra true yet or new rock stars it's
either going to come back positive or
negative and you know billy mount wants
to know greg are you gay with john
people think we are and maybe we should
just let it be that way because the part
what makes a good sitcom work will they
or won't they and oh they will
oh this is getting good brandon and son
happy birthday now you have to punch
john this is gonna get out of hand this
is gonna become like cheap thrills have
you ever seen cheap thrills he'll do
anything if you super chad a super cat
it's my birthday - thanks Britney Lance
hey Britney lean with him I just got
punched well I love how this has become
the thing that for for this live stream
of what will Gregg do to John for
Craig's person hello in Alabama over 40
I will another epic Rap Battles will
cover their stuff no although check out
the one where they get a bit locked yeah
check out the one with the Burger King
and McDonald's and Wendy's because my
homegirl is Wendy oh that's awesome
yeah hey Jon you're so hot the ladies
love Jon oh you know what's even hotter
than jon is a greg i used to say you
know it's like we used to have girls on
here like eight times a week like my
brother anytime and then I say Jabby the
girl and message Abbi brings on like
eight huck or and and then i said [ __ ]
that i'm just gonna replace all of them
with john tom how we got Sean here to
supplement my hair so yeah I'm like
neither there needs to be a bit of a
mislead upon looking at the thumbnail oh
yeah you don't look at faces first Oh
hey Lana thank you for everything you
rock
she's real that's what she always says
right really what a real person would
say cuz real be warned I'm real wait
there was a question in here what's your
favorite character on attack on Titan
Greg oh man Levi it's Aaron them knees
the lead but Levi man he's just the guy
you wanna be hey now my favorite
characters are always the ones where I'm
like I'm gonna be that guy and Levi he's
the bat he'd like to me he's just so
Liam badass of mysterious and rarely
emotes and when he does you're like this
guy [ __ ] feels I love that I love
that the best present I ever got
well my girlfriend just got me tickets
to go parasailing I've never done that
before that's a very unique experience
experience so I have you know to me
right now that's the best one what do we
think about the Joker reviews cool did
their review I'm just happy I guess that
it's kind of divisive and supposedly
very distinct that's all I want
yeah I mean it's it sounds it almost
exactly like what I expected there's the
one thing I've noticed that a lot of
critics have been saying this is one of
those movies where I'm like I'm gonna
read reviews yeah one thing that critics
have pointed out is how they
and to be honest I think it was more so
Bibi Fanta that girl looks a certain way
can it be a fan of content you put out
oh it's kind of cute that she was
offended by that oh I'm sorry
come on we don't want every didn't mean
it as an effect and three-minute is just
making this is poking some fun thank you
oh no I know we love you in a pretty
sure you're not about your appearance it
was more like are you a robot is is
that's pretty much it you're out yeah
it's pretty much it and honestly if
you're a female
that's just how we tend to go must be
baby who's so interested was talking
about right before that um you know
stuff oh yeah the Joker yeah yeah I
think the joke to me they're almost
exactly I expected like regardless of
what people think of the movie itself it
seems like people think Joaquin
Phoenix's performance is brilliant and
to me that's the most important element
yeah that's the most important side of
it all and it's just the fact that it
has the great reviews it hasn't the fact
that it's been a little bit divisive of
people that just gets me more excited I
wouldn't want just mainstream generic
Nisour something that's just safe you
want this to be edgy and do something
really different it sounds like that's
what it's doing yeah no matter what I
have heard I've heard the movie goes for
broke and that's what they should do
right right Britney thank you who do you
think plays a good Joker are you asking
who do you think could play a good Joker
no just out of the ones we've seen
instead of the ones we've seen who is
not sucked Jared Jared Jared the best
easily donator is the best who could be
a good joke to Cameron Monaghan from
Gotham just needs to get his own live
action like he needs he should just be
in the movies if she really should a
whole stand alone Joker I'm at the part
in Gotham watching out patron out where
you get where we get to where he's been
resurrected that is I'm just like man
this guy is so mesmerizing as the Joker
and he really feels like a comics
version of him and in such an authentic
way I really hope he can become be
someone to put and play The Joker one
day but if I wanted a deep voice Joker I
would say Javier Bardem I feel like
you'd be an interesting Joker if he was
like someone who goes for a deep voice
Joker yeah
okay okay Sam Elliot Sam Elliot all
right guys I'm gonna log off in just a
couple minutes I gotta go meet up with
some peeps but I do want to say thank
you again
and Lana from Hawaii we didn't meet her
awesome like we meant it you got to
think about it we met in elementary
wayans really think about it it was a
complimentary is this what you get as
men you can't compliment women on the
internet anymore you know how it goes I
like that you're alive and real and you
are here in this room yes
maybe maybe blend it with one more
question John get a good one in all
right let's see let's see let's see who
what what 80s movie do you think
deserves a Netflix prequel series like
The Dark Crystal
what 80s movie The Terminator I want to
know what Sarah Connor was doing before
a Connery show yeah I was going on with
her dude spin-off about her roommate you
know what was her day in life like what
futures and aspirations that you have
I'm always gonna I guess I'm gonna die
on this hill but if they could assemble
the right cast and keep the tone proper
I don't know if I want a prequel but
maybe like a buckaroo banzai
could be left field enough to be like if
Netflix announced that I would be like
let's do it yeah nice to mention all
right guys thank you so much for being
oh thank God we got validation from Lana
sure okay okay good oh thank god can't
have God it's been a long week been a
long week and it's only Tuesday
we don't under the no we don't know who
gets our satire or not and we have this
attitude of like you know it's satire to
stop getting hurt and then when we find
out someone's hurt or like damn it we
heard how do we just be immune to that
all right guys thank you so much for all
your birthday wishes thank you to
everyone who chimed in here seriously I
think it's been a great past year like
the year it's like since John I
partnered up a couple years ago
it was like a whole thing where we came
in at the harsh time in YouTube and
honestly the past literally 365 days
have been a hell of a journey and it's
been very rewarding it's been great and
I'm just so happy to be here and I'm
excited to keep making videos because
everything has really been on the
upswing lately and so much amazing
things have been happening thank you so
much everything double headphones
animation thank you for being here
you guys Rock and hopefully I can get
some sleep tonight so in case anything
big drops tomorrow if we happen to miss
it that's purely my fault not his
much love to you guys thank you again